there are just five days left until the
u.s deadline to pull out of afghanistan
and hundreds of american citizens are
still there the u.s military has already
helped evacuate more than 95 thousand
people since august 14th one of the
largest airlifts in american history the
biden administration says many of those
still in afghanistan are dual citizens
and have not yet decided to leave u.s
ambassador ross wilson said this to cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell last night
people chose not to leave that's that's
their business that's their right
uh i i we regret now that that many may
find themselves in a position that they
would rather not be in
and we are determined to try to try to
help them
the state department has told americans
not to wait outside the kabul airport
because of the risk of a possible terror
attack delta is operating more than two
dozen flights to help afghan refugees
and americans who have been evacuated
from kabul now this comes as the airline
tackles another challenge encouraging
employees to get vaccinated unvaccinated
delta employees must take weekly covet
tests from september 12th and starting
in november those in the company's
health care plan who are still not
vaccinated will have to pay a two
hundred dollar monthly surcharge delta
ceo ed bastian joins us now to discuss
good morning ed bastian it's always good
to see you this is quite a message i
think you're sending to your employees
because 200 a month certainly adds up
and a big wake-up call for people who
have not been vaccinated what is the
message you're sending
well good morning gail good to be with
you as well we need to get everybody
vaccinated that's the message the
cost can't be measured in dollars it's
the the tragedy that
covett has raked on all of us on our
businesses on our families we've got to
do our very best to take care of each
other there is a financial cost as well
and if you decide at delta not to be
vaccinated post november we're going to
hold people accountable for
shouldering some of that cost but you're
not requiring mandatory vaccines how
come
you know it's a difficult decision
when you threaten people with the loss
of their livelihood
and there are some people that have some
very deep-seated concerns i've talked to
many of them about the vaccines i don't
agree with them i do my best to
encourage them but we wanted to give
people an option if they really can't
take the vaccine not to have to lose
their job i think we're going to get we
already are at 75 percent of our entire
workforce vaccinated i think gail will
get well over 90 with these additional
steps we're going to take and at that
point we've effectively vaccinated our
entire workforce have you gotten any
backlash from your employees about these
new policies
i've gotten backlash from some employees
i've had other employees cheer uh
unfortunately in today's society
whatever you do you're going to be
critiqued that's true
and by the way we're just all we're
looking to do is just take care of our
people and continue to push them to make
good decisions and have you thought
through the question of possibly
requiring vaccinations for travelers who
are boarding delta airlines
well it exists now today if you want to
go internationally so as an american if
you're vaccinated you can travel to
europe if you're not you can't and i
think as international borders open
you're going to see vaccination
requirements continue to grow don't see
that happening in the u.s though you
wouldn't do it is that a mathematical
calculation because clearly there's a
certain percentage of passengers who
don't fly because they don't feel safe
and then there's another percentage
who would not fly if you made them get
vaccinated to fly have you worked the
numbers
it's really not about the numbers as
much as the fact that first of all our
planes are full people are flying in the
u.s where there's a tremendous demand
tremendous surge of demand of interest
in uh in travel
in the uh in the air but you also look
at the logistical dilemma of we're
carrying millions of people a week of
trying to figure out who's been
vaccinated who's not who qualifies for
an exemption uh it would actually
bottleneck the domestic travel system so
the system working in the us today is
great our planes are clean their people
are safe they're fully masked probably
the safest place you can be on board is
a u.s
airline today in the u.s but we do have
requirements going forward
internationally i've often wondered
about the dilemma for delta and i
thought you all did a very lovely thing
to a little girl we carried it here on
cbs this morning her name is delta she
wasn't feeling so great about her name
and you all sent her a lovely care
package to say delta is a really good
name to have i wonder if it's caused
problems for you at the airline i notice
in your release you call it the kovid
delta
i don't i don't refer to the uh to the
official uh varian name uh if anything i
call it the darn variant
but
is it are you you said business is still
strong i mean with the surge in cases
recently have you seen any fall off and
flying or are you worried about that
we've in the advanced bookings we've
seen some choppiness primarily around
the business traveler businesses are
delaying their reopenings or pushing
them back anywhere from 60 to 120 days
because of the variant i don't i don't
expect it's going to have a material
impact on our on our results we'll
what we're doing well we expect to be
profitable this quarter even with a
considerable amount of our revenue still
not back yet uh team's doing a great job
hey ed uh delta airlines is heavily
involved with getting afghan refugees
and evacuees and americans out of
afghanistan can you tell us about those
efforts and what the next steps are
well we're honored to serve
we volunteered for this so before the
craft missions were even required we had
already stepped up and provided crews
and aircraft willing to serve
we've carried several thousand i think
over three thousand refugees back out of
safe uh into safe territory here in the
u.s they're emotional missions the
people that we're carrying back
are leaving only with the clothes on
their back and you know many of them
don't have shoes on their feet so we're
doing a great job of taking care of them
getting them safely home we've got great
partners like walmart stepped up
yesterday and provided pallets and
pallets of food and and necessities baby
materials uh hygiene products for these
people who don't have anything when
they're on board our planes
it's an impressive effort uh it really
is
from delta and some other airlines as
well ed bastian thank you very much for
joining us this morning and could you
spread the word to other ceos about
mandatory vaccines and maybe raising
insurance policies i think need to send
a message to people getting the vaccine
is so important yeah glad you're leading
that really is it's it's
it's it's critically important and we're
doing our best to lead thank you always
good to be with you guys all right ed
take it easy